okay people are doing this on Tick Tock
they they just repeat affirmations like
I'm a lucky person or everything works
out for me and then they just watch the
luck roll in and Tick Tock users who've
tried it swear their luck changed
immediately but experts say it's simply
because the Mantra makes the brain focus
on moments that make them feel lucky
instead of dwelling on negative events
but that's what I like about it yeah
what do you mean how why just power of
positive thinking I don't think you can
wish for things I do think you have to
go out there and earn it and work for
things I've always battled with luck but
there's a mentality here going on that
feels uh like an affirmation base
totally it's perspective yeah if you're
a Negative Nancy it's shocking how much
negative stuff comes your way Nancy
Debbie Downer